so my talk is called down the rabbit
hole it's a little story about a crazy
bug I was chasing around for two and a
half months earlier this year my wife I
came home from work up for like three
days in a row my wife asked me what I
was doing at work I said chasing a bug
and finally she was like why shouldn't
you be working why are you chasing a bug
around the office it's like I've done
right so this is like a little play sort
of there are six acts I have a cast I am
in the cast that's me that's what I look
like on the internet I work for a
company called a lark we put live chat
on websites so this use a little chat
box in the lower right-hand corner you
might have seen it around it's popular
among the startup community this little
bird is going to help give advice
throughout the talk and this is the app
that had the bug it's it's an odious
based app that allows our operators to
chat with the visitors on their website
from their web browser so they don't
have to download any software on their
computer it's basically a jabber client
that runs in your web browser it's built
on nodejs and socket i/o among other
things all right so let's get started
Act one is denial a few months ago a
customer came to me and said the chatwal
crying it keeps disconnecting and
reconnecting I said my code is perfect
there's no way that's happening it must
be your problem
for those of you who don't know what
pebkac is it means that the problem
exists between the keyboard and chair
this is my problem that often exists
between my keyboard and chair anyhow
it's basically just user error well then
a couple days later another customer
came to me and said hey the cat chat
client keeps disconnecting and
reconnecting yeah absolutely sure maybe
that maybe it's just a crappy internet
connection a couple days later one of my
co-workers came to me and said hey my
chat client keeps disconnecting and
reconnecting it's definitely easier this
time just kidding sorry Sam but he did
say hey my internet has been flaky
lately and so I said sweet flaky
internet problem hi thought so so
problem solved get better internet its
end of my talk no
just kidding so first piece of advice
from the OL ark advice bird is to listen
to your users they actually use your app
probably a lot more than you do so
sometimes they actually are telling the
truth so on to act to acceptance fine
there is a bug so I wonder how often
this bug is happening like it was just
two people in my coworker than yeah okay
maybe it's not super high priority but
if it's like everybody then all right
you should probably fix it so my first
instinct is all right let's go look at
logs we have logs logs the big they're
helpful they're text
blogs and arts happen to be in JSON and
they have hashtags in them because
that's just what we do so we actually
were logging an op disconnected hashtag
every time someone disconnect so if you
stuck this log or if you graphed every
time someone disconnected it looks
something like this peeking around 30 or
so per minute if you look at our total
connection graph it's roughly in the 350
range at a maximum so if we have a
maximum of 350 connections and
disconnects around 30 that means ten
percent of our users are disconnecting
every minute which is actually like fine
it's a problem yeah great lesson number
two and I'm going to lose count of these
so I'm stopped counting but graphing is
really helpful it only took a few
minutes for me to figure out how many
people were being affected once I need
to look basically and we have a lot of
graphs like this for this particular out
can you read that
anyhow these come in very handy like
after deploy to check and see if
everything is gone okay or if you've got
a higher rate or whatever I highly
recommend having some dashboard with
graphs on it for your app now let's go
back to logs so this is a UNIX system
and I know how to use this stuff so
let's take the log look for all the
optics connects it happen in it and this
is not a standard UNIX tool but since
their logs are in Jason there's this
cool thing called Jason tool that you
should look at if you are in a similar
situation and you can basically pick out
pieces of your adjacent particular keys
in the object and get rid of everything
else it's like you know it's what you
wish you could do with XML easily on the
commandment and probably but anyhow so
this basically up to this point will
give us a list of all the usernames
every day every time a user name gets
disconnected it prints out their
username so if we sort it by username
and then count up all of the unique
instances of that username and then sort
it again by the number the count of that
thing oh yeah you need to do that if you
want to actually run that we get
something that looks like this it's like
in this log file Steve disconnected once
John disconnected twice and Susie
disconnected 512 x so okay
Susie obviously is having something
crazy going on so let's go back to more
eunuchs okay this slide is not working
there we go okay so get the disconnects
again this presenter cool thing has
totally failed this time we will get the
timestamp and the user name out of the
Jason and then filter just Susie stuff
and take the first field which is just
the timestamp so really all we're
looking at is what are the times that
Susie's client disconnected and when I
looked at this I noticed this is
happening almost exactly every minute
plus like a tiny little millisecond
delta it's going for 45 or 46 for 47 and
448 so that's kind of weird like a
minute is sort of a big coincidence if
you ask me so the bird says log things
because it's really useful to look at
the logs and be able to figure something
out without just like sticking in print
statements or something and also know
how to use your tools so you can take
your logs throw it through a thing I
mean the command line and all that
command line stuff took me a couple
minutes to put together if I had to like
write some program to do that would
taking a lot longer all right so Susie's
definitely having a problem none of us
except for my co-workers to near had
actually seen this on our computers and
we'd been using for a couple of months
before we released it to any customers
so but sooner did say something that was
interesting he has flaky internet so how
can we simulate flaky internet and see
if we can reproduce it
I tried doing stuff with iptables about
a half an hour I said screw it I
unplugged my ethernet cable and I had
flaky internet success unplug ethernet
cable wait plug ethernet cable back in
and it reproduced the issue it got into
the reboot reboot loop and was doing all
its stupid annoying stuff that I want it
to do so the lesson here is just do
something like you know at some point if
there's something stupid you can do
that's going to work when you're chasing
a bug especially I mean you know maybe
not when you're writing like nice
production code but but if you're
chasing around a bug like just do what
you need to do to figure out what's
going on and worry about later maybe
also learn your tools later why is this
thing working ok anyhow next to act
trying to figure out what is actually
going on so I looked in Chrome's
developer tools you can read this right
and so if you click on the network tab
in Chrome's developer tools you can then
click on the web sockets tab down there
which will filter the list at the left
for websites is a very intuitive UI that
like that filters that and if you click
on frames you can see each little bit of
data that's transmitted through the web
socket it's very useful for web sockets
debugging I figured it out about like
two days after I needed to figure it out
but in retrospect very useful but
there's no closed event that happens at
the bottom so like it just the WebSocket
just sort of stopped at some point
so I decided okay I'm gonna figure out
what's going on one way or another I got
wire shot going I TCP dump hey hello
where are you I guess I have to do this
right so this is a Wireshark dump of one
reboot loop that happened and if you
look here this is the WebSocket being
forcibly closed on the client side I
happen to know that because I know the
IP addresses but Wireshark is like a
super awesome tool if something is going
weird at the protocol level you know
other idea what's going on the newest
version can dissect WebSocket stuff so
it'll tell you like everything that's
being sent through here like in the
payload it knows all this stuff so it's
like five colon colon colon name visit
blah blah like this is this is the data
that's going across the protocol and its
really really helpful for when you're
logging and stuff is not enough and
chrome developer tools not enough to
figure out what's actually going on so
check out Wireshark if you got some
really weird protocol thing going on so
anyhow I looked at that and basically
what it told me is that the client side
was what was closing the connection it
was not the server dropping it or
kicking anyone off so I'd at that point
I that's like a small amount of useful
information at least I don't have to
mess around with the server side and
thanks chrome for not telling me that
the client side was the one that was
classic section so I just decided to do
what I call Shotgun debugging and stick
break points everywhere in the socket
i/o a source code that said close
because you know at some point when I
was being a called let me be able to
trace it back and this actually worked
it took me a long time to turn all the
breakpoints off later it's probably bad
with that and basically the issue was
that the old web socket was being
swapped out for a new web socket when
like when the client reconnected and
this was supposed to build in one at a
time but revealed ijs is being broken so
the old website there the old websockets
heartbeat does not get properly cleaned
up and the old heartbeat happens after a
minute later the disconnect heartbeat
gets executed so then it kills the
WebSocket the new WebSocket that's there
and then new web sockets like oh hey I
got disconnected I better reconnect and
then its heartbeat I thought doesn't get
cleaned up so then every 60 seconds when
the heartbeat time out finally times out
kills the WebSocket starts over again so
we actually had some cases where there
were oh this happened to people had
flaky enough internet that they they
were getting disconnected four or five
times per minute and so like there would
be a timer at like four seconds eight
seconds 30 seconds 42 seconds and it
would just like keep killing over and
over again those bats bad bad bug that
was affecting quite a few users and so
the fix was basically just I mean this
is an absolutely terrible fix because
like I didn't actually fix the heartbeat
time out or whatever like basically I
just wrapped the thing like that calls a
heartbeat I'm out to make sure that's
actually closing the socket of a
heartbeat time I've got fired on and it
worked
are you kidding me
just a second
this is a cached or something I swear
there is literally a graph in here and I
saw it like ten Mohs
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna Wireshark this
real quick I don't know I don't know why
oh there's zero indexed
yeah it's probably also flaky Internet
hey did have another graph that was just
like said graph and didn't like this
should have been other graphs anyway so
we deployed this and it was up around 30
and it went down to like one so so it
was really obvious when it happened
because we had these these grafts here
so my point about graphs is is a good
one I think anyhow sorry about that
basically I I came up with a few life
lessons after this this two-month run
around with this bug like I added a lot
more graphs so I could see what was
going on all the time I logged all sorts
of added a bunch more logging about
events that were going on so we could so
we could trace future issues I have been
much more willing to just pull my
ethernet cable out instead of trying to
figure out iptables when I'm trying to
chase down a nasty bug i also meant to
go back and figure out how how to
actually do it in iptables maybe later
but most importantly I learn to listen
to my users more because they definitely
is this a lot more than I do we're up to
900 concurrent connections at peak now
so this there's 900 more people than me
who's using it and that's it
you